everybody for sticking it out sneak
louder he's gonna be talking I'm just
gonna do a very quick introduction I'm
not saying anything important well this
is actually the session I'm most excited
about from the entire week know if
that's the other speakers use talker
great I really resurgence of interest in
interior point methods our pleasure to
have skeet right you've kind of the
first two lectures kind of sending out
perhaps what would be like a authority
call this right view the right view of
how to think about interior point method
was one of the pioneers in this area in
the 90s and written wrote my favorite
text on the subject and so he'll give
the introduction and then we'll get cut
the more contemporary view and the
applications to kind of the discrete
side of things from addendum Adri and
Aaron's differed in the subsequent
lectures right from the University
sponsored great thank you Ben is such a
pleasure to be here too
ok so here's an outline
I'll start I'm gonna talk mostly about
LP and I think the two colleagues that
are following me Aaron and Alexander
also are gonna focus mostly on LP of
course the interior points have a much
broader scope than that and I'll mention
a few of those extensions here to
quadratic and programming and LCP linear
complementarity okay I'll talk a little
bit give you a bit of background about
Newton's method central path Central
Park neighborhoods primal dual path
flowing you'll spend a lot of the
lecture on that talk a little bit at the
end about primal and dual barrier
methods which are things that Alexander
and Aaron are more interested in I would
say and then talk about the relationship
between these barrier methods and these
path following methods of primal dual
methods so I'm not going to give too
many citations right because back in the
90s they used to be flame wars would
break out you know people would would
get very upset if you wouldn't credit
the right people for the right ideas
fortunately that was the days before
Twitter so these flame wars that would
take place on email so the
bandwidth was a little bit more limited
but we certainly did our best to make
our feelings felt in those days but I do
want to acknowledge that there were
there were tremendous contributions
particularly towards the stuff I'm going
to talk about from people here in this
program so I'm gonna run the risk of
leaving important people happened you
knew yeh was a very important
contributor Jim ran a guy back in the
90s
Levent contributed a lot ok I'm already
blanking am I missing out anyone
certainly those three people and I'm
really sorry if I if I left your name
off no leave it of course sorry leaving
Lehman's name is up here so if you want
to look for more information about
background elaborations and what I've
talked about take a look in these books
there's the classic time of nice job and
nemirovsky in 94 published by siam there
was my book from 97 Yin you published a
book around the same time these are
Levin's slides for his lectures for EE
236 C I think so if I get that wrong
but anyway this is a very beautiful
concise summary of some of the main
theories surrounding particularly
surrounding barrier methods and self
concordance he and sort of summarizes
some of the important stuff of Nesterov
nemirovsky and are very easy to
understand form and then Jim Jim I
forgot to mention Jim okay but Jim wrote
this beautiful monograph in 2001 about
the mathematical theory behind interior
point methods and he was one of the
pioneers actually going back to the 80s
in this area okay all right so so he's
kind of a statement of philosophy pretty
that I just want to preface the talk by
there is beautiful theory underlying
interior point methods beautiful
analysis very elegant they're also
required the development of kind of new
areas of analysis self concordant
functions self scale barrier functions
and cones primal-dual potential
functions all these ideas that came up
in the 80s and 90s and this theory is
really important in going beyond LP
two more general conic programming
particularly two SDP you need this very
elegant general formulation to make that
jump and here are some papers that sort
of carry out that that sort of work in
that domain of that elegant general
mathematical formulation there's an SDP
review paper by Tod I've already
mentioned this book I've already
mentioned leaving slides and I've
already mentioned Jim's book but all of
these have you know take that sort of
mathematical viewpoint that's you know
very refreshing and very powerful
however the thesis of this talk is that
you can get an amazing amount done using
very elementary mathematical tools and
that's the approach I'm going to take
today most of the time towards the end
I'll switch and make the connections a
few other connections with this theory
but I do want to I do wanna stress and I
do want it demonstrate to you that you
need to know almost no math to prove
polynomial complexity of an algorithm to
solve LP and I think that's really
remarkable that it's you can do so much
with such limited tools and in fact I'm
going to give you a complete polynomial
convergence proof and demonstrate to you
that it is possible to do it using very
basic tools even after lunch okay which
is always a challenge okay so some
reviews of linear programming so just to
maybe fix notation and to remind you of
some of the basic theory so this is a
notation I'll use minimize a linear
function over a polyhedron polyhedron
defined this is what some people call
standard form I guess that's what I call
standard form where the general
constraints are equality z-- and the X's
are constrained to be non-negative
variables a is an M by n real matrix and
I'm going to assume full rank although
that doesn't that issue doesn't come up
much except when it comes to solving
linear systems which you have to do and
then you sort of need full rank nice to
get well potent supposing this of the
linear system and so on so let's assume
we've got full rank you can always do
pre-processing if necessary to make sure
that's true okay so you can write down a
jewel of this maximize B transpose e
where B is from the right-hand side here
a transpose e less than or equal to C a
again as the matrix see is a primal
objective and and you can introduce dual
slack so you can introduce has to
capture the difference between the left
and right hand side here and the dual
constraints so that's a that's the way
that will stick to this is a formulation
we'll use where the dual variables are Z
and s and S is non-negative okay and
then you can write down KKT conditions
kirusha kuhn tucker conditions which are
optimality conditions simultaneously for
the primal and dual so these involve
both primal and dual variables they
consist of the feasibility conditions
for the primal and dual problem with one
extra condition at it this crucial
condition of complementarity that says
that the X and s vectors have to be
complementary to each other so that
means that their inner product has to be
0 that's one way of saying it another
implication of the non negativity
combined with the complementarity is
that all of the components of X and all
the components of ours have to be
non-negative obviously and if you take
pairwise products of XA times si that
has to be 0 in other words one of the
two needs to be 0 at least for all I
okay so that's a condition that's kind
of hard to satisfy because it's the only
nonlinear condition here all the other
conditions are linear all right so
there's a theorem that says if you've
got a triple x es satisfying these
conditions then the x solves the primal
problem and the zs solves a duel ok all
right
LP duality very powerful theory
developed I guess in the 50s mostly
first of all is weak duality and that
just says if you've got a feasible point
for the primal and a feasible point for
the dual then the primal objective of
the thing you're trying to minimize is
bigger than or equal to the dual
objective which is the thing you're
trying to maximize and on Monday that
was proved twice on Monday I think by
Pablo maybe maybe Pablo on someone else
so I won't do it again
well actually oh well it's on the next
slide it's it's hard to avoid writing
down that proof it literally is a
one-line proof ok literally a one-line
proof ok strong duality this is a very
powerful theorem this says it if you
consider the primal and dual pair
exactly one of these three things is
true
okay the first thing that's possibly
true is that they both have solutions a
primal and the dual and at optimality
their objectives are equal okay that's
the first possibility the second
possibility is one of the two is
unbounded and the other was infeasible
unbounded means it's feasible but you
can drive the objective to infinity or
minus infinity on the feasible region
okay so that's the second possibility
and the third ones that they're both
infeasible so this doesn't cover all the
bases you know this theorem tells you
that for example you can't have one
problem being infeasible and the other
one having a solution you can't have one
problem being unbounded and the other
one having a solution more ever tells
you if they both have solutions the
objectives are equal so this this
actually says a lot this theorem and
this previous actually go the other
thing to notice is it doesn't need a
Slater condition when you prove this for
SDP very often you you need a strictly
interior point that's not true in linear
programming
okay you can get away with a lot more in
LP the proof is a lot trickier than weak
duality in fact one of the standard
proofs uses the fact that there is a
method that solves these problems namely
the simplex method and that if you apply
the simplex method with appropriate
rules for avoiding cycling and so on
it's guaranteed to terminate okay so you
actually need the algorithm to prove the
theorem which is slightly weird state of
affairs but there are other proofs as
well but they're certainly more
complicated than than the one-line proof
here okay so what about duality and
complementarity well if you've got a
pair mostly for most of the talk I'm
going to be assuming that your primal
and dual candidate iterates satisfy all
the easy conditions they satisfy the
equality constraints and these
inequalities they're all linear and so
when you're considering methods that
generate iterates and I'm going to be
talking primal-dual methods so it
generates iterates in the primal and
dual space simultaneously there are
going to satisfy all of these conditions
and if you've got a point that's primal
dual feasible then here is the one-line
proof again okay if you take the inner
product of X and s because both of these
vectors contain non-negative entries
they're in a product
is greater than or equal to zero if I
substitute for s from this condition
here I get I get an equality if I just
expand that out I get here a times x
transpose e pay times x equals B okay so
that second condition collapses to B
transpose e and there we have that C
transpose X is greater than or equal to
B transpose e again okay so the reason I
write this out though is not to give you
a third proof of weak duality but rather
to point out that one way to keep track
of how close we are optimally
is to keep track of this inner product
and in fact we we denote this by mu we
denied mu to be one over n times that
inner product and that's the thing that
we're going to try to drive to zero
because if we're maintaining all these
conditions and we drive this to zero
we're heading for a solution okay
primal dual solution so this mu is a
very important quantity another way to
think about it is it's the average value
of the X I times si pairs okay it's the
average of all of these pairs all of
which need to go to zero at the solution
it turns out it's the same right it's n
times mu okay so if these points are all
feasible if these conditions are
satisfied that's exactly the same thing
yeah
okay so we're gonna use this notation a
lot where we take a vector and make it
into a diagonal matrix so I take the
components of X string them out along a
diagonal put zeros everywhere else in
the off diagonals and to get a matrix
big X same thing for us and now also
I'll use a like this vector e which is
just the vector of all ones okay so
using that notation I can rewrite the
KKT conditions like this where I here's
the primal feasibility his dual
feasibility here are the non negativity
constraints and then the last condition
here is a complementarity so if I
multiply x times s times e I simply get
this vector here where the I entry is
just X I times si okay and I want that
to be 0 as well so if I can find an X Z
and s that first will satisfy these
linear equalities non-linear equations
that one's nonlinear and these
inequalities I've got a primal dual
solution so what primal dual interior
point method to do is to try to solve
that that system okay so that's the
approach and foremost the talk I'll be
talking about maintaining strict
feasibility with respect to the easy
conditions strict feasibility means I
want the components of X and s to be
strictly positive that's why it's called
an interior point method ok strict
feasibility with respect to those
conditions and we need these equality
satisfied at all iterates we're going to
take mutant like steps on this system if
you look at this system it's a square
system right the number of unknowns if
you count up the number of X's YZ and
s's there's 2 n plus M where n is the
number of rows in a n is the number of
columns so it's 2 n plus n unknowns
there's also 2 n plus M equations here
so it's a nice square nonlinear system
with these extra conditions added on
so it we're gonna I'll describe Newton's
method in a moment but we're going to
take steps that kind of look like Newton
steps for that system let's denote them
by these this Delta notation we're going
to take steps along those that Newton
Direction usually not full steps usually
we're going to pick some alpha that's
between 0 and 1 because these conditions
are all or because these conditions
our Linea then after we take the step
they'll continue to be satisfied I'll
explain that more in the next few slides
we're going to make sure that we choose
the alpha so that these conditions
continue to be satisfied after we take
the step and we're hopefully also going
to decrease the value of MU okay so as
you move from XK to XK plus one
hopefully Mew will shrink as well and
we'll be able to say something about how
fast it shrinks and thereby get get
convergence and complexity results okay
and here's the other critical thing
that's really crucial the success of
these methods we try to make the X I
times SOS will decrease to zero at
roughly the same rate that's the secret
okay at roughly the same rate so in
other words we sort of keep track of the
difficult the ratio between X is a and
mu which is the average value of the
exercise and we want that ratio to more
or less gonna stay bounded okay
not go to zero that can be done
explicitly as it will be in the methods
that I'll talk about it can also be done
implicitly which is what happens when
you're using a primal dual barrier
function
it basically maintains that condition
but in an implicit way okay what about
complexity how do we get pulling ami
ality well what we're going to be able
to show from these methods is you get a
decrease in mu this duality get measure
from one inner to the next
and typically the decrease is a factor
of this form one minus some constant
independent of n times n to some power
where this power here is typically 1/2 1
or 2 depending on what method you're
talking about but usually in
conventional interior point methods at
least 1/2 okay so you guaranteed this
factor of decrease in the muir at every
step that's typically what you can show
now everyone knows how to convert that
into a complexity there is the standard
argument I want to figure out how many
iterations will it take me before I can
reduce Miu K by a factor of epsilon over
where I start at musi row ok well a
number of iterations is going to be the
value of K such that this factor raised
to the power
is less than Epsilon okay so I can take
the log of both sides there I can then
use the fact that log of 1 plus T is
less than or equal to T for all T
greater than minus 1 okay we've got this
very nice Universal bound for the log so
I'll use that bound here to about two
lower bound this log term so then I get
this condition and now I simply divide
both sides by minus C and to the minus
mu because I'm dividing by a negative
the sign the inequality flips around and
I get a lower bound on the number of
iterations okay so in other words when
you get this amount of decrease that
translates into a or to enter the new
log epsilon iteration complexity count
all right cost being tolerance Epsilon
how do you translate about them you do a
bound on that well that is the duality
gap right so it measures the difference
between primal-dual so by definition is
kind of measured the difference between
the primal and the primal optimal value
because the optimal value is sandwiched
in between the two feasible values okay
all righty
so a little slight very slight diversion
on Newton's method for nonlinear
algebraic equations this is something
you probably all learned in your very
first numerical analysis course back
thirty years ago I remember when I was a
postdoc and my colleague Mike Shelley
who's now a very distinguished applied
computational mathematician at at
Courant and also he works for the Symons
Institute in Manhattan but he said to me
at lunch one day well optimization is
just Taylor's theorem you know that's it
that's the whole thing and of course
he's not that's not true because as
we've seen this week there were many
other optimization brings in many other
things in the case of Newton's method
that it kind of is true you know largely
so this is really just tailless here and
this is the Taylor's theorem derivation
of Newton's method so the basic idea is
if you've got a square nonlinear system
of equations mapping RN to RN say you
can write down a first order Taylor
series approximation this matrix J is
the Jacobian it's just the N by n matrix
of first partial derivatives where I
take one of the components of F and
differentiate with respect to one of the
components of W okay so
the first order Taylor series
approximation if f is smooth enough then
the remainder term is going to be little
o of D in fact it's going to be O of d
squared if if things are sufficiently
smooth okay so the idea of Taylor's
theorem of Newton's method is you just
pick the D to make the first order of
approximation zero okay because after
all you want to find a value that makes
F zero so you pick the D to make that
zero at least and then you define D to
be that step and that's given explicitly
by just minus J to the minus 1 times F
okay so if I plug that into here at
zeroes out this part all I'm left with
is the order of D or little o of D which
is little o of this and so if the
Jacobian is is is non-singular at the
solution and you're close to the
solution W star say then the the inverse
of the Jacobian is upper bounded ok and
so this little o of D term turns into a
little o of F of W term okay and so what
does that mean that means after you take
the Newton step you managed to reduce F
of W to little o of F W so you get super
linear convergence and if everything's
smooth enough it's going to actually be
quadratic convergence okay so here is
the picture you would have seen in like
second you numerical analysis here is
the equation here's the f of w we're
trying to find the zero of we're trying
to find that point there and so in one
dimension J is just the slope it's just
the gradient so if I start off at this
point here I take the slope at that
point I form a linear Taylor series
approximation and I find out where it
crosses the x-axis and I take that to be
my next tile later it my next Newton
iterate so W 0 moves to W 1 I just
repeat the process and as you can see I
converge very quickly to the W star
there okay so that's an asymptotic
result that quadratic or super linear
convergence applies only when you're
close to a solution sorry I'll go back
and cover those two slides in a second
but an interesting question that we
should consider here when we're talking
about interior point methods is what
happens when you're outside that
of quadratic fast convergence that's
really the issue here because we're
going to be applying Newton's method or
this Newton idea far away from this
domain of quadratic convergence so you
really need some sort of more global
theory than what I've just shown you in
general if you're just dealing with
general functions there isn't really any
guarantee that newton is any faster than
a first order method you can construct
functions where Newton's method takes
you know as many iterates as a gradient
method however these are very special
functions we're dealing with here
they're almost linear except for that
complementarity term when you're dealing
with barrier functions and this is what
I'm not going to talk about much they
have this property called self
concordance and self concordance is this
beautiful property that says that the
third derivatives in some sense are
bounded in terms of the second
derivative so that the later terms and
the Taylor series are not going to bite
you too badly by cutting it off at the
first or second order approximation
you're not losing too much so if you
compute the Newton step and apply an
appropriate scaling to it you guarantee
that you make a certain amount of
progress okay so that's the that's
really the key property here in showing
that this Newton type approach has good
global behavior so going back to where I
was I'm sorry I should have done this in
sequence but I told you about Newton's
method for non-linear equations because
that's the important thing to talk about
when we're doing primal-dual methods
when you're doing barrier methods primal
or dual barrier methods is a more
important topic is Newton's method for
minimizing a function so this is a
function mapping R into R typically I'll
assume it's twice Lipschitz continuously
differentiable here you take two orders
of Taylor series approximation you go
out to the second order and then you
pick the D to be the one that that
minimizes this second-order Taylor
series approximation and here is the
formula it looks a lot like the one that
I had before in fact it's kind of you
get the same formula by applying
Newton's method to nonlinear equations
to just the the gradient of F you get
exactly the same formula okay in this
minimization setting though you can
there are a few more things that are
sort of of interest in analyzing to
repoint methods the first one is if you
plug the optimal D into this second
order of rocks
Meishan you can find out the predicted
amount of decrease you're going to get
over this step so I'm moving from X to X
plus D it's telling you that f is going
to decrease by about this amount or by
about that amount okay and so if you
look at that leaving slides or the
Nesterov nemirovsky book or many other
papers on this topic they introduce
notation for this lambda of Arc
X and they call it the decrement for
this term here and you can prove things
about the decrement you can prove things
globally about the decrement notice I've
got an approximate equals here but in
fact if you've got this property of self
concordance going on you can you can
make this more rigorous you can get rid
of this less enter this approximate
equals and put some sort of qualifier
here and get some actual guarantee I was
at least a certain fraction of the
predicted amount of decrease and that's
the key to polynomial complexity of
primal or dual barrier methods okay so
getting back to path following which is
where I was a few slides ago so this is
a system that we're trying to solve
actually I've I've changed a little bit
here I've perturbed it by this factor
here tower times e so remember e is a
vector of all ones tau some positive
parameter so that's new here this this
thing here and this this thing is is
kind of the thing that stabilizes a
little bit okay so instead of heading
right for the solution we say well let's
let's tweak the non-linear equations a
little bit to get a system that's a
little bit easier to solve in some sense
okay so i'm going to think of the
solution of this system as being as is
carving out something called the central
path and you can show that if the set of
strictly feasible points for the primal
and dual is non-empty you can show that
this system has a unique solution for
any positive towel there's a unique
triple xes that satisfies this system
okay so the central path in primal dual
space is well-defined and we're
essentially going to use the central
path as kind of the highway that we
follow to the solution that's the
intuitive idea so rather than taking
Newton like steps on that on that system
I showed you a few slides ago we're
going to take Newton like steps on this
system that's
idea and it's a little bit less
aggressive instead of making a beeline
for the solution we're actually heading
for a point on the central path why do
we do that it means that we're less
likely to bump into the boundary okay
the trouble with heading right for the
real solution is you get stuck up
against the boundary trying to satisfy
these constraints if you're a little bit
less aggressive by choosing a positive
value of tau you're able to move along a
distance along the Newton direction
before you bump into the boundary yeah
exactly if I expand this out it's
telling me that X I times this o is
equal to tau for all I yeah I mean
everything is subject to scaling here
yeah yeah that's true you can you can
mess it up if you if you take rows of a
and start multiplying by huge numbers
you can make life more difficult all
right so that's the idea this is a very
important concept in path following
methods is the central path that's the
path that that we follow okay so we need
to talk about neighborhoods because of
course if we insist that we're always
right on the central path that's going
to be a lot of work to get there so
usually we're satisfied with staying
within certain neighborhoods there are
different ways to define neighborhoods
board they all have in common is that
you're trying to ensure that these
products X is are not too different from
each other okay and one way to define
them is to say well they're not too
different from their average value which
is mu viewers the average value here so
there are a couple of ways to measure
neighborhoods these are the two most
common ones the first one says that if
you take the vector of X I times s is
that vector where you know X 1 s 1 X 2 s
2 and so on down to xn SN and you
subtract off the vector of Mews which
are their average values that the 2 norm
of that vector is less than or equal to
theta times mu where theta is something
less than 1 between 0 that's a 2 non
neighborhood there's another one which
is the one I'm going to talk most about
which is a more generous neighborhood
that one just says you pick some value
of gamma between 0 & 1
typically you choose it to be quite
small
ten to minus three say and you insist
that all of the X is is are at least
gamma times mu so that within a factor
of a thousand of their average value
okay there can't be no one can be way
closer to zero than the others now this
is a more generous neighborhood than
this one if you let gamma go to zero you
eventually encompass the whole strictly
feasible space okay but if you let theta
go to one that's not true
even if theta is very close to one
you're not you're not approaching the
whole strictly feasible space and you
can't let theta get bigger than one
because then you'd start admitting terms
where the X I times si is negative so
you can't allow that okay so this
neighborhood is more generous this one
actually gives nice and complexity
results though as a [ __ ] factor of N
which I'll mention again a little bit
later on yeah I mean just I'm just
curious
I've tried myself and I got very
confused is one of these like easy to
relate to the Newton decrement yeah
there's gonna be some analysis about
that yeah and I've got some pictures as
well so hopefully they'll become clear
as we go okay so here's a strategy okay
change the notation here sorry but the
idea is we define a target point on the
central path we pick a value of tau
which kind of defines a point that we're
heading for we take a Newton step based
on that system of algebraic equations
towards that value then we choose a step
length to move along that direction we
choose that step length so as to stay in
whatever neighborhood we've chosen okay
now what we're going to be able to show
in fact I'm going to work with that
second neighbor at the end infinity or n
minus infinity neighborhood what we're
going to be able to show is you can stay
in the neighborhood taking steps of this
type and achieve this amount of
decrement so for some Delta independent
of n you're able to show a decrease
factor 1 minus Delta over N and so
that's going to translate into an N log
epsilon complexity yes
that should be minus infinity that's
this neighborhood here when no nope
airwaves product can be too much smaller
than the average okay all right so
here's the whole method I'll call it
long step path following so this is a
notation we use I use this notation here
to give you a step along the Newton
direction at XK all right so it's just a
shorthand for this alright so here's the
strategy you pick a gamma that defines a
n minus infinity neighborhood you pick
Sigma min and Sigma max they're both
between 0 and 1 you choose an initial
point which has to be in the
neighborhood okay then in each iteration
you do the following you pick a Sigma K
which is somewhere in that range and the
Sigma K defines the target value of tau
so you define your target to be Sigma K
times mu K where mu K is the current
value of the average shoe allottee gap
so because the Sigma K is less than 1
you're sort of aiming for a point that's
a little bit further along the central
path than where you are right now ok the
point on the central part that
corresponds to this iterate you can
think of as being the Mew K and we're
trying to move tool from the Mew Cape
oint to the Sigma K mu K point so we're
aiming to make some progress ok and
Sigma K is less than 1 so it's going to
be closer to 0 than where we are now
ok so you calculate that Newton step you
then move along that direction as far as
you can while staying within the N minus
infinity neighborhood and I'm going to
show you in a moment that you can take a
significant step you don't immediately
get jammed up against the boundary of
the neighborhood and then that's the
step ok that's all there is to it
yes oh yes that's a very important point
which I talked about later on okay so
when I give you the complexity result
I'm taking this as a given okay but yes
that's a very important point we have to
have a good way of generating point in
that in that neighborhood to do that you
just have to solve a bunch of quadratics
because if you look at the way the the N
minus infinity is defined its XA times
si greater than or equal to the average
XA times si is just going to be
quadratic in alpha right and the
right-hand side which is the MU
corresponding to this is also been going
to be quadratic in alpha so you just
have to solve a bunch of you have to
solve in quadratics and alpha that's it
okay so that's order in ya take the
smallest one exactly yeah okay
so let's dive into some of the details
of this first of all this is the Newton
step for F tau where tau is Sigma times
mu so I've just written down the Newton
equations that's the Jacobian of this
system here okay when I take the first
partial derivative matrix of that system
it's almost all linear so most of the
terms in the Jacobian are actually
constant there's an a there's an a
transpose and as identity here here it's
not linear but when I differentiate x
times s times e with respect to X I just
get s left over and when I differentiate
with respect to hair so I get X okay so
that's where these terms come from
that's the derivative with respect to X
that's the derivative with respect to s
and then the right hand side is just the
current value of the function of that F
of tau function at the current point so
I'm assuming that I'm currently feasible
with respect to the linear equation so
those two values are zero this is the
residual with respect to the the last
the third block so I plug in the current
X and s here I plug in the current tau
and that gives me the right-hand side
here in this Newton system okay so
this is a system that defines the steps
alright I can break down that last row
that third row they're intuitive
individual components cuz these are both
diagonal so if I look at it one
component at a time I just get s a times
Delta X I plus X I times Delta si the
corresponding component from the right
hand side is just minus XO I si plus
Sigma times mu all right I can sum that
over both sides and I'll get this turns
out to be useful later on believe me
okay well I shouldn't say believe me
because that's that's a flag these days
but I'm about to tell a lie that's what
but I don't mean I'm about to tell a lie
okay so I have to stop using that phrase
all right okay so if I sum both left and
right hand side it from y equals 1 up to
n I just get s transpose Delta X here I
get X transpose Delta s here I get minus
X transpose s which I've already told
you as n times mu and then here when I
sum that up from Michaels one day and I
just get n times mu times Sigma so if I
keep track of what's happening here the
the summation here is just minus 1 minus
Sigma times n times mu ok so it sort of
tells you the linear prediction of how
much you're going to decrease the
average the duality gap the scale
duality gap essentially now if you look
at this system this is a linearization
of that f of tau system the f8l system
is almost linear as it stands the only
thing that's stopping it being a linear
is the x times s times so the only thing
I've left out here you know if I put in
the Delta X Delta s times e term I'd
have actually an exact relationship I
would have solved the nonlinear system
so the only thing that's stopping X plus
Delta X Z plus Delta Z s plus Delta s
actually solving the original system is
this term ok so that's the term that I
need to keep track off I want to keep
track of how big that is how far I am
from actually you know the difference
between this system and the real system
that I want to solve the real nonlinear
system so again I'm using this notation
where I'll take Delta X and I'll turn it
into them
matrix by just spreading a tellement
south along the diagonal and so these
are going to come up in the analysis so
analysis is mostly concerned with
showing that this term doesn't get too
big so you don't pay too big a price by
ignoring it in this Newton approximation
okay so here's this diagrammatic picture
that sort of explains what's going on
with these methods and it's a nonlinear
geometry but I think it's very it's
nicely illustrative so here I'm dealing
with a case where there are two
variables little N equals two and I'm
plotting on the x-axis the product X 1 s
1 and the y axis X 2 s 2 so in that
geometry the central path is just this
line at 45 degrees where the X is I x1
x1 equals x2 s2 ok the N minus infinity
neighborhood is just the one that says
they both have to be roughly the same
size so I can't have extra west to being
way smaller than X 1 s1 or vice versa
so the boundaries of this N minus
infinity neighborhood are these dotted
lines ok so I can sort of illustrate
what's happening at every iteration by
saying ok if you give me the current
point it corresponds to a point in this
kind of weird geometry if you calculate
the Newton step it traverses a quadratic
path in this geometry right because the
path is parametrized by alpha and x
times X I times si is a quadratic in
alpha as I just mentioned a moment ago
so these you can think of as being
quadratics I stop as soon as I hit the
boundary okay I picked the Alpha to stop
when you hit the boundary and then I
just repeat that process now how do I
know that I'm always heading inside well
the Newton step if I take a
linearization of that initial direction
that the trajectory is carving out it's
actually heading for the point on the
central path defined by Sigma times mu
ok so the first order you're heading for
this Sigma times mu point but of course
because of the non-linearity introduced
by the Delta s times Delta X time it
sort of tends to veer off and then bumps
into the boundary again and that process
repeats but turns out you can move a
significant distance before that happens
you don't just immediately go infeasible
you can take a reasonable step and
that's a secret to showing that you
a reasonable decrease every time okay so
I'm not going to go through all this in
detail because it's to 10:00 in the
afternoon but this is the complete proof
that if you start from an initial point
that's in the N minus infinity
neighborhood important caveat but if you
just give me that I can give you the
complete proof of complexity okay ending
up by showing that you get this amount
of decrease at every step and these are
just five statements the proof of each
is exactly one slide and each one
follows from the one before so it's just
a chain of implications the first one is
purely technical if I take two vectors
in RN with a positive inner product then
it's sort of an implication of the
geometric arithmetic inequality as we'll
see on the next slide okay so you and
matrix U and matrix V are just what you
get by spreading I needed to have diag
here sorry I need diag in front of those
but it's what I get by taking U and V
and just making diagonal matrices out of
them okay from that I can deduce that if
you take the two particular steps the
primal and dual steps and take the
matrices generated by those and apply
this result I get this inequality that
sort of bounds how big the non-linearity
is essentially using that and using the
fact that the current access is in the N
minus infinity neighborhood I can find a
bound on the right-hand side here okay
so that's how I get to statement three
from that and this is kind of the key
step from that I show that I can move at
least this far along the along the
search Direction that is all alpha
between zero and this upper bound a
guaranteed to be in the end minus
infinity neighborhood so I'm not going
to bump into the boundary what's that
well gamma defines the N minus infinity
neighborhood okay that's the that's the
thing here it's something between zero
and one okay and the Sigma the Sigma
here that actually needs to be Sigma min
okay but the Sigma defines the range of
values of Sigma that that define how far
along the central path you're trying to
move how much decrease you're trying to
get out of this iteration okay so you're
able to show that you can take a
significant step and then it follows
from that that you get at least this
amount of decrease on the current eater
so it's just 1 implies 2 implies 3
employs four employs five this is
actually the most technical one
and Alexander forbade me from proving
this so I'm not going to go through it
all but I'll just point out that all it
is is a consequence of the scalar
arithmetic geometric mean inequality you
just take the u transpose V you break it
up into terms where the U is positive
the UAV goes positive in the UI video is
negative you use the fact that the two
norm is less than the one norm I don't
know that's pretty much it that's yeah
that's pretty much it
okay I'll leave you to contemplate this
later on if you if you want to follow
all the details but but but that's it
that's the first statement okay so how
do we apply that to get the second
statement well the second statement
remember is this bound here so the trick
is to figure out what to call you and
what to call V and it's not what you
think it's not u equals Delta X and V
equals Delta s you actually need to
apply a scaling to them to them and the
scaling you get by taking the X in the
ass
the current iterates the diagonals
formed by the current iterates taking
their product and taking the negative
square root of that and you get another
diagonal matrix now remember X and s are
both strictly positive so all this is
well-defined x times s is a positive
diagonal matrix so I can take it's
negative square root and what I'm going
to do is hit both sides this is the
third row of equations in the Newton
system I'm going to hit both sides by D
well actually yeah by D now hit both
sides by D and I get this kind of scaled
version of that system so now we're
going to apply that first technical
result yes there are methods that are
based on doing that operation and then
doing a Newton step right like meaning
that you guys well there are things some
of the methods for stp basically do that
yeah they're sort of nested scaling yeah
but we don't necessarily need to you can
do that I think you can do that for all
P but we don't have to okay so okay so
when I okay so I get this I define U to
be this guy V to be that
and so this is telling me what u plus V
is and u plus V is the thing that comes
into the right-hand side of this of this
first technical result so applying that
first result I get that the u times V
times e because of course u times V if I
multiply that out the D inverse and the
D cancel okay and so I'm just left with
Delta x times Delta s times e so that's
how I get that there's less than or
equal to 2 to the minus 3 over 2 times
the norm of this thing the stuff on the
right hand side squared ok so that's a
straight application of the first first
result so that's the proof of the second
one ok the proof of the third one well
all I need to do is to just take the
right hand side from the second
inequality it's the square of a vector
it's the two norm squared of a vector I
just expand it out when I take the inner
product of this thing with itself I just
get X transpose s when I take the the
cross product the XS to the 1/2 cancels
with the XF to the minus 1/2 and I just
can t transpose e ok times the scalar so
that's nice and then when I work on the
last term there that's a little bit more
complicated but again I use the fact
that X s belongs to this n minus
infinity neighborhood so then I know
that these interpro I know that these
pairwise products are greater than or
equal is gamma x miu okay so when I take
the inner product of this with itself I
get 1 over X is I but I can upper bound
all those terms because of this
inequality here I can upper bound by 1
over gamma x miu okay and now I just
take the use the fact that e transpose E
is just n I can just mash it all
together and I get this up about okay so
that's the that's the third one the
important thing to notice about the
upper bound is has got an it's got an N
in it that turns out to be significant
that's where the order n log epsilon
complexity comes from and it's also got
a mu in it that's important to why we
might expect that that end is being
passed
there's some loss in this kind of
analysis yeah it's not it's not obvious
but when you go to using the two norm
neighborhood that end sort of turns into
a square root of end for reasons that
maybe have something to do with like the
inequality between the two numb and the
one norm I'm not sure but I don't think
there's an obvious way to keep using
this in the big wide neighborhood and do
better than they say and I don't think
there's an obvious way right
you solve proving that even if you're at
the boundary in terms of one of the yeah
if I go back to this picture here if you
don't put that if you don't put that
Sigma damping term in you're going to be
trying to take a Newton step directly
for the solution here and the danger is
that as soon as you start moving along
the direction they're going to go
infeasible okay so so being aggressive
and aiming for this that is an algorithm
by the way it's called affine scaling
and I'll talk later about algorithms
that use directions like that but you
can't just use it at every iteration
because you may never make progress
so by as I mentioned earlier by putting
in by just targeting a point that
somewhere further along the central path
the Newton step starts out heading for
that point okay so the tangent to this
direction is actually going to be a
point on this central path so that's
telling you that you're going to start
out moving internally to the to this
neighborhood now as to the fact that you
can actually move a substantial distance
before you hit the boundary again that
really comes out of that analysis I'm
not sure how to do that intuitively
but that comes out of those three
inequalities that I just proved there's
another question yeah all right
okay where's unit that's always true so
that's true the first step and we picked
this step to make it true at all the
subsequent it hurts
okay so we're explicitly enforcing that
the towel the towel is the Sigma times
mu so it's ours much to my generic
notation for Sigma times mu which
changes it every iteration yes yes yes
it's change you're trying to shrink it
to zero so you're trying to at every
iteration you're trying to move a little
bit you're targeting a point a little
bit further along the central path
towards the origin okay
yeah gamma should be large or small
quadratic links alone yeah
in practice you sort of pick gamma to be
small close to zero to give a nice way
to give a lot of latitude what price are
you gonna pay for that well not too bad
I mean if K well if gamma is small I
guess the upper bound and alpha gets
kind of small and so the theoretical
complexity might suffer a little bit but
it turns out that in practice you kind
of want it to be small big no it's big
yeah it's almost the whole the whole
space then okay but you do go to play
this is one of many instances that I'll
talk about later where the practicality
kind of is in conflict a bit with a
complexity okay I'll mention that I'll
say a little bit more about that later
on okay so we proved the third statement
we're up to one two three now let's see
we've got up to here this one here this
as I said is the critical one this
actually I lied to you earlier when I
said believe me I was actually lying but
this one actually takes it it takes a
flight and a half rather than one slide
okay because as I pointed out talking to
Ben earlier you want to show that you
stay inside this neighborhood by taking
a step out for along the path so you
have to keep track of what's happening
to the X is is which is the left hand
side of the inequality defining n minus
infinity gamma you also have to keep
track of the right-hand side which is
Mew of alpha they're both quadratics
okay the X is a product I just expanded
out using the definition of what you get
by stepping in distance alpha along the
Newton direction the term involving
alpha you know exactly what that is
because of the the third block of the
Newton equations okay the third block of
the Newton equations was just this okay
so this tells you right away what the
coefficient of alpha was okay the last
term here we just worked hard to bound
that term
the product the non-linearity the
product of the two steps primal and dual
we've got an upper bound on that and
that's what I used that comes right out
of formula three so I'm able to lower
bound the right hand side the X I X I
the X I si by this quantity which is
quadratic and alpha okay I can say
exactly what the right hand side is the
end x miu of alpha again by just
expanding out what do I mean by X of
alpha recive alpha again I write it out
as a quadratic in alpha I again use the
third row that all that hard work I did
back here when I summed up the
components of the left and right hand
side that gives me the coefficient of
alpha in the expression form U of alpha
so I can replace that by this okay and
so that gives me this coefficient here
that's what I've done to get to the last
line and again I've got I can use that
upper bound on Delta X Delta s to bound
that last time no in fact I don't have
to do that I tell a lie that actually is
zero that turns out to be zero and did I
prove that somewhere I can so two of the
Newton equations are that a times Delta
x equals zero and a transpose Delta Z
plus Delta s equals zero okay so if I
just take that last one and multiply it
by Delta X transpose
okay I just get the first time goes away
because I got eight times Delta X equals
zero so I'm just left with Delta x times
Delta s equals zero okay so and that's
what I use that's what I used to get rid
of that lost okay so that goes away so I
actually just get something here that's
a linear in alpha and I can say exactly
how it depends on the current value of
MU defined by the current hitter so I
can show what happens to MU as I take a
step along alpha as a function of the
current value of MU okay so so now if I
if I ask the question how big can I make
alpha and still stay in this minus
infinity neighborhood as long as I can
show that the Alpha is big enough so
that this is bigger than that then that
alpha is okay all right this is a lower
bound on the left hand side this is
equal to the right hand side so that's
all I need to do that's the lower bound
on the left hand side this is the right
hand side I can just figure out what's
the biggest alpha that makes this true
that's it there okay so that gives me an
upper bound on the Alpha that I can take
of course you could possibly use bounds
to get that so the Alpha in practice
could be longer than that but that's all
that's you can go at least that far when
gamma is small that expression is just
multiple units what's gonna be done it
so it goes it's small its small yeah
gammas will make this up advance mole
yeah yeah which is a little bit
counterintuitive
this is kind of intuitive the the Sigma
so the Sigma is what factor a decrease
you're trying to get out of this step
okay so if you're trying to be really
aggressive and you're trying to go from
mu 2 mu over 10 M you over 100 you know
so in other words Sigma is 0.1 0.01 then
you won't be able to move very far
because you're being really aggressive
and you're sort of targeting a point
close to the solution so the fact that
it should be upper bounded by a sigma
makes sense but the gamma is a maybe a
little bit less intuitive it's just I
guess it sort of says that you're
playing with fire if you're going to
allow it allow a very wide neighborhood
I guess you're always operating close to
the boundaries yeah you always operating
very close to the battery so you're only
gonna be able to take small steps small
but not but not trivial yeah okay okay
okay and there's the last one this fits
on one slide so this is what happens to
Moo as you step along the distance
camera so we just have to keep track of
MU as a function of alpha I know that
because this is linear and alpha and
because Sigma is less than 1 this is
actually decreasing for alpha between 0
& 1 so our best strategy is to move as
far as we can until we hit the boundary
we just proved that we can move at least
this far before hitting the boundary so
that gives me a bound gives me an upper
bound on how bad you K of alpha is here
it is here and that's exactly what I'm
looking for so this has the form 1 minus
Delta divided by n where the Delta
involves here the Sigma min I guess I'd
be conservative and involves gamma it
involves 2 that's it right and the N
only comes in here okay so that's here's
the adult here so that's what we needed
to get a polynomial time complexity
result and nothing I used yeah Sigma
Sigma between 0 & 1 so I'm bounding
Sigma strictly away from 0 and 1 you can
pick it adaptively in fact practical
methods use adaptive heuristics to pick
Sigma well this is suggesting 1/2 but
you know how much credence do you place
in worst-case analysis but in practice
you know maroa came up with is very
slick heuristic in like 1989 which was
basically an adaptive way of choosing
Sigma essentially with a few other bells
and whistles but you know the thing is
when you get close to the solution you
can get more aggressive you can pick
Sigma to be closer to 0 when you're
further away Sigma equals 0.7
point a you know is pretty much
guaranteed to give you a nice decent
step okay so that's it that's a complete
end-to-end except for choosing the
initial point analysis of polynomial
complexity of this long step path
following method okay let me talk about
how I got five minutes good yeah okay so
I can tell you about some other variants
that use basically the same idea namely
solving this this system this algebraic
system targeting a central path point
here's the method that uses a much
narrower neighborhood the end to
neighborhood which as I pointed out
earlier is not nearly as generous as the
N minus infinity neighborhood so if you
start out in the end two neighborhood
you can you cut you compute Newton steps
it turns out that here as long as you to
find the inter neighborhood by theta
equals point four you can actually take
a full step and stay inside the
neighborhood you don't have to do a line
search that's why it's called a short
step path following method so no need to
choose an alpha you just guaranteed to
stay inside the method the neighborhood
you also have to choose Sigma like this
just a little bit less than one one
minus point four divided by square root
of n okay so it's a very conservative
strategy it's just kind of creeping
towards a solution and guaranteeing this
amount of decrease at every step but
this ends up with better worst case
complexity you get a square root of n
instead of an N okay and these are the
best known results for these kinds of
methods a square root of n however this
is slower in practice you can implement
this perfectly easily it's very easy you
know it's trivial to implement you just
need a linear equation solver to compute
that step but it turns out to be slow
yeah we'll talk about that yeah we'll
talk about that okay here's another
variant and this is probably the last
one I'll talk about before the break
this is a so-called predictor corrector
so this one I can sort of draw a picture
to illustrate what's going on here this
one actually worked with two
neighborhoods a wider one and a narrower
one and it doesn't predict the
corrective thing it starts out in the
narrower
neighborhood and then takes a Newton
step but stops at the boundary of the
wider neighborhood so it has to do a
line search to make sure that it doesn't
violate the white a neighborhood and
then then it does a corrector so it
computes a step from that point with a
goal of getting back into the narrow
neighborhood and in the corrected step
you don't try to move any distance along
the central path you just try to recover
centrality with Eggman without making
any progress so what does that mean
let's go back well what it means is that
in the second Newton step you're just
solving F of MU K there's no Sigma here
you're just kind of trying to recover
centrality while not trying to decrease
them you in the predictor step you do
credit try to decrease them you in fact
you you you try to decrease them you all
the way to zero okay so you take an
aggressive step targeting the the
targeting the actual solution of the
primal dual LP pair so why don't you get
stuck at the boundary because you're you
you're starting from the inside
neighborhood and you can you don't have
to stop to get the outside neighborhood
so you can make a significant step along
along that aggressive direction because
of the gap between the two neighborhoods
okay so you alternate between yeah
alternate between these taking these
aggressive steps and taking these
corrective steps which is just trying to
recover centrality so you can think of
the the sorts of method I've described
earlier it's kind of hybridizing between
these two instead of switching between
zero and mu you take some intermediate
value Sigma times mu see you're sort of
rolling the two steps into one okay I
think is a good time for a break this is
also square root of N and the analysis
is very similar to the yeah it's it's
very similar to short step path
following so this is also better than
long step you can actually show that it
converges super linearly but it's still
slower but on the earlier iterations
okay time for coffee
[Applause]